‘Member that time I talked about stem cells?
Ohhh, I ‘member!
Hey cell mates, Julian here for DNews.
We’ve been cranking out episodes for four
years now.
Can you believe it?
Over the course of the next few days, the
hosts from DNews are going to celebrate our
birthday by having a look back and revisiting
topics from our first days with the show.
I have talked about a ton of fascinating stuff
but I still remember my first episode, when
a fresh-faced and over-enthusiastic me couldn’t
wait to tell you about an exciting new experimental
treatment involving stem cells, cells which
can take the form of other tissues and hold
the promise of regenerative medicine.
Since then, what’s been going on in the
world of stem cells?
Well, a lot.
Like, a lot a lot.
Hardly a week goes by without stem cells making
a headline for one thing or another.
Here’s a brief sample of some from the last
two years.
Scientists successfully created mouse eggs
from stem cells that produce healthy young
pups when fertilized.
Stem cell therapies on people with traumatic
brain injuries appear to reduce the body’s
neuroinflammatory response, saving brain tissue.
And cardiologists are testing stem cells as
a treatment for a type of heart failure that
kills half its victims within 5 years and
previously had no treatments at all.
Oh, did I say those were headlines from the
last two years?
I meant the last two weeks.
So obviously the pace and variety of stem
cell research is immense.
Looking back to my first episode, though,
we focused on what was then a new treatment
for vision loss caused by macular degeneration;
that’s when part of your retina starts to
deteriorate.
It wasn’t the first time stems cells had
been used to treat macular degeneration.
In fact, a month after my DNews debut, a report
published in the Lancet followed up on 18
cases of patients who had stem cell procedures
on their eyes up to three years prior.
The patients showed no signs of rejection
or tumor growth, and for 13 of them their
vision had improved on average about 3 lines
on the eye chart test.
You know the one with the huge E and then
a bunch of smudges?
Anyway, the story I covered was special because
it was the first use of induced pluripotent
stem cells, or iPSCs, on a human.
The cells were made from a patient’s own
skin that had been turned back into stem cells
using a virus that delivered new DNA.
Before that, scientists used embryonic stem
cells which may have a risk of rejection to
go along with a thorny ethical dilemma.
Sadly, the woman who received the induced
stem cell treatment remains the only person
with that distinction.
The researchers had a second procedure planned,
but halted it when two small mutations in
the cells made them worry they would lead
to tumor growth.
That hasn’t been the end for iPSCs; in fact
they’ve become invaluable for laboratory
work.
They’ve been useful for drug screenings
and scientists can study diseases by introducing
mutations to the cells using the breakthrough
gene editing technique CRISPR.
And because iPSCs are so similar to embryonic
stem cells but can be produced easily and
ethically, stem cells are in a much greater
supply than ever before.
In fact, their creator, Shinya Yamanaka, isn’t
resting on his Nobel laurels.
Using a protein called BMP, or Bone Morphogenetic
Protein
, he discovered a way to turn adult cells
into stem cells more frequently.
This can increase the supply and further accelerate
and diversify the research.
So two years on, nobody else has received
treatment using induced pluripotent stem cells.
But that doesn’t mean there’s been no
progress.
Scientists are finding new and interesting
uses for them all the time, but they’re
going slow and making sure the treatment won’t
do more harm than good.
Like we always say, more research is needed.
We all having embarrassing pictures of us
when we were younger, but I’m not ashamed.
There is my first ever DNews episode right
there.
Epic flail!
Are there any other old DNews episodes that
stick out in your mind that you’d like us
to follow up on?
Go ahead tell us about them in the comments,
subscribe for more and we'll see you next
time on DNews.